[Música]
porque aprender yo creo que es una
cuestión que le llega mucho las personas
que son empresarios menores
y lo personal me ha llegado cuatro veces
a lo largo de mi vida laboral industria
tecnología información la primera vez
que me llegó esta pregunta fue con
estaba ganando la universidad
porque normalmente complejas
universidades tienen dos alternativas
una es
emplear una gran organización sabe
escalar puestos y posteriormente
la otra opción que tienes es
evidentemente emprender
por la primera persona que le pregunté y
se ve como ves me recomiendas y mamá me
dijo independientemente de la opción que
tomes tú tienes que ser un líder que nos
quede un poco confundido no estaba
respondiendo mi pregunta y empecé a
practicar con amigos yo soy ingeniero en
cibernética de la universidad la salle y
eso escuchaba cuando estamos saliendo de
la universidad las historias de que
fulanito tal ya trabaja en cierta
organización en esta corporación ya se
certificó porque eso era muy importante
entonces da mucho valor las
certificaciones y pues también escuchar
los salarios muy bien algo interesante
en ese momento y por otro lado tenían
las historias y otros amigos que estaban
emprender saliendo en la universidad
tenemos suite commerce que habían
empezado a comercializar
servidores encantadoras tipo de hardware
para los clientes fracturas historias de
fracaso
entonces la primera vez que llegó esa
pregunta mi mente decidir si no
emprender
entonces me empleé empecé a trabajar
industria de información en mi primer
empleo como en el instituto mexicano
seguro social posteriormente estuve en
axa estuve en el sat también trabajando
para grandes organizaciones como hp como
ibm
[Música]
queridos y empecé a escalar puestos
empecé a ser arquitecto
entonces por primera vez en mi vida me
encontraba
experimentando un caso de éxito del
emprendimiento fue muy interesante para
mí porque estar trabajando al lado del
dueño era muy interesante entender cómo
se administra un negocio cómo se
generaba negocios como el proceso
comercial el proceso de ver y por esas
fechas
vi a mi socio a hugo justamente
estábamos acabando la maestría de
curiosamente hubo minera director de
tecnología de otra empresa de
consultoría
japonés
platicamos nos veíamos y dijimos oye sí
ya los dos somos directivos porque no
aprendemos ya vimos cómo es manejar un
negocio señor entendemos bien
y en poco tiempo
nació
empezamos página web
de presentación vídeo todo muy fácil
un buen mensaje
a nuestros clientes rumí inició una
empresa de desarrollo de software
desarrollo software para empresas un
modelo de negocio y tubey y poco a poco
dispuso en el cliente claro que éramos
muy buenos últimos de la industria
consultoría industria tecnología
información y empezamos a obtener
clientes empezamos a monetizar a lo
largo de dos años llevamos una
organización siempre implementar
sin embargo en ese momento
que ya habíamos tomado la decisión de
emprender nos dimos cuenta que lo
habíamos hecho por la razón de obtener
más mil y esa fue la razón por la cual
empezamos a emprender debido a que como
estábamos acostumbrados a trabajar con
el director general y los directores de
tecnología nos las respectivas empresas
la lógica fue pues ya no podemos aspirar
a un mejor sueldo ya el siguiente
sueldos en su sede el dueño de la
empresa por eso emprendimos en lo
personal para obtener más de esa fue la
segunda vez que llegó la pregunta del
por qué emprender ahora se tomó la
decisión de emprender pero no fue el
último
entonces el rubin siguió creciendo
seguimos teniendo más clientes cuentas
muy interesantes muchas historias de
éxito muy padres pero nos dimos cuenta
con una consultora de tecnología
información
difícilmente vamos a escalar un negocio
al punto que nosotros buscábamos porque
ya habíamos pisado ese primer escalón
del éxito buscábamos ser reconocidos es
algo importante buscábamos una nueva
compañía
[Música]
nos dimos cuenta que la tecnología para
que sea adoptada masivamente tiene que
ser tecnología enfocada en el consumidor
que las historias de éxito que nosotros
seguíamos partiendo ese principio de
desarrollar tecnología hacia el
consumidor no hacia las empresas como lo
hacíamos entonces
entonces tomamos la decisión de generar
tecnología para el consumidor
yo voy a por silicon valley
daniela un verano justamente con la
intención de conocer de siempre estas
grandes corporaciones estas empresas
historias de éxito y sobre todo conocer
el conocer todo estar que es muy
importante versus lo que yo sabía de
emprendimiento de una consultoría en sbk
y coma
que su capital la explosión de la
interna de las cosas inteligencia
artificial el escalamiento de
organizaciones en poco tiempo regresó la
ciudad de méxico y les digo a hugo es
entonces a otros compañeros del equipo
que tenemos que crear un robot
un robot de consumidor un robot que
tuviera las características necesarias
para ser un asistente de control del
hogar
una historia excelente entonces nos
pusimos manos a la obra y en ese momento
me di cuenta llegó la tercera vez que
tomé la decisión decidir el camino
correcto seguir emprendiendo porque al
final del día era un modelo de negocio
nuevo desarrollar robótica versus
software y la respuesta fue sí voy a
emprender pero el motivo era diferente
el motivo era el reconocimiento
empezamos a ser un equipo fuerte en este
momento se une por nuestro equipo y
nuestro tercer socio un gurú cuanto más
inteligencia artificial contratamos más
ingenieros y desarrollamos el primer
robot comerciales
recordó mi que lo presentamos en una
feria de tecnología de blancos y fue un
boom mediático se estaban haciendo
robots mexicanos dos comerciales
mexicanos un éxito estamos en todos los
medios no sólo méxico varios países de
latinoamérica
entrevistas invitaciones a participar en
foros y habíamos logrado ese segundo
objetivo que del reconocimiento
entonces trazamos un plan un poquito la
verdad deslumbrados por el éxito que
hemos obtenido para llevar ese robot con
su inhumación la realidad es que ese
plan no se le robe fue muy frustrante
porque no lo obtuvimos primero que nada
inversión de capital para materializarlo
pero sobre todo nos dimos cuenta que no
había una demanda de los usuarios en
américa
la adopción de la internet de las cosas
en américa latina hace cinco años era
prácticamente nula estamos hablando que
no existía el exámen existía borbón y
difícilmente las familias americanas
iban a adoptar
robots humanoides
esto fue balde de agua fría teníamos
ciertos inversionistas arriba del barco
cierta gente que confió en nosotros pero
por más que buscábamos como si
materializar ese despliegue más tuvo
robos todos encontrarnos con paredes y
nos empezamos a ajustar los socios tal
grado que pensamos en cerrar la cortina
de ilusión
mi socio y yo teníamos muchas ofertas
laborales a la par de esto por la
posibilidad de hacer otro negocio dado
sin embargo justamente en el momento en
el cual íbamos a tomar la decisión de
cerrar tengo que cerrar la cortina
de continuar en esta aventura de
crearlos para la lección los mexicanos
recibimos un reconocimiento el 'martín
uno de los institutos más importantes de
investigación en el mundo nos había
reconocido como los innovadores más
importantes de américa latina que se ha
formado
sólo siendo reconocidos por elementos
nuestra tecnología y reconocida por el
e-mail
hicimos una pausa yo en lo personal me
puse a reflexionar qué es lo que estaba
pasando que lo que estábamos haciendo
bien y la respuesta fue clic
méxico es líder en investigación de
robots y con 19 constantemente gana más
competencias
ganando buenos lugares con nuestros
ingenieros mexicanos
somos cantera de investigación y
desarrollo
cuál es el principal problema que
nosotros no tenemos una visión de
negocio para crear tecnología comercial
de cara a ese poder de investigación y
desarrollo
justamente en ese momento me di cuenta
que más que todo el marketing que más
que una necesidad de adquirir un
producto comercial un robot ya sea para
consumidor y para empresas había una
oportunidad para hacer crecer no sólo a
mi empresa sino al país entero
con el desarrollo de tecnología con el
desarrollo de robótica podríamos generar
una economía de escala global por las
capacidades técnicas que tienen sus
ingenieros sumado a las grandes
oportunidades en cuestión de salarios
que podemos generar
entonces los hicimos fuerte y vote a
nuestro modelo de negocio una vez más
hacia el concepto de between a vender
robots a las organizaciones con la
intención de empezar a describir los
primeros robots humanoides en casos de
uso y empezar a hacer que los usuarios
finales se normalizarán con tracción con
robos y eso nos logró empezar a escalar
como organización
en ese momento llegó la cuarta vez que
tenía que decir si emprender y el por
qué emprender
la respuesta en esta ocación fue muy
sencilla me di cuenta que mi propósito
es transformar la sociedad
ayudar aquí no sólo los miembros de la
organización crezcan sino el país
creo firmemente en que en méxico podemos
desarrollar tecnología profunda exportar
esta tecnología profunda y con la
tecnología generar un vehículo para que
sea en materia de manufactura
investigación y desarrollo y
comercialización
ese propósito es el que me ha mantenido
hasta ahorita en el camino del
emprendimiento y cada vez de que sufran
esas bajadas de rollercoaster
muy difíciles me afianza continuar en el
camino
creo que son mis propósitos hubieran
sido dinero hay 20 mil formas de hacer
dinero ya me hubiera bajado del camión
y poco estudiadas y la fama
reconocimiento creo que hemos obtenido
hasta cierto punto
tropas
pero cuando hay un propósito más potente
como es la responsabilidad del
crecimiento de tus seguidores del
crecimiento de la sociedad
difícilmente vas
ahora entiendo por qué en ese entonces
yo tenía que ser un líder
un líder se forma en el momento en que
se responsabiliza de que su crecimiento
no sea sólo para él mismo sino de todos
sus seguidores
y entre toda la sociedad